foreign
almost ready how's everybody doing today
all right what's up everybody uh i am
sam from
python basics we are going to be
continuing
on with our little series of uh
studying python an introduction to
python
a really in-depth all-encompassing glad
to have everybody
here today sorry about throwing
everybody a curveball
last week had uh life going on
and uh couldn't um
couldn't really get back quite in time
and get all
or uh in order but we got some admins
uh in place uh we do have
open chat today so this is gonna be
uh a little bit different than the last
ones but
super excited so all right let's just go
ahead and jump into it
so today we're going to be looking
at a little board game i'm really going
to be focusing on lists
and a couple of
yep i that's that's one of the things
is if you want to you want to make a
joke tell tell life you have a plan
okay but here here's the little layout
that we're going to do
and so basically
a little board of circles or zeros i
think it's o's it's actually o's
and then there are some hidden x's and
we have
a two-dimensional choices so
we have a lot to do here but some little
cleanup work
that i want to do is
there were some questions hanging out
there about any
and all so i thought
now would be a good time before we got
into that to go ahead
and handle that and also then in turn
that is going to lead us into some list
comprehension with conditions and i
realized that i did not go
over how to really handle
conditions in list comprehension if
anybody can remind me
jan or cardinal did we
did we do those
i don't remember and then we also need
to uh
talk a little bit about strings because
we're going to use that in our board
all right so
all right all right so list
comprehension with conditions
now this is where it gets a little odd
so we're going to look at
this right here
and when we bring this in and we look at
it so we have
a list then it has
some a string okay an ant
another string ant string and a string
all right now let's just say that this
got handled wrong
i want to also show you this about
uh strings i don't think we looked at
is numeric so python has handled this
for us
actually i you know i may make my kid
laugh and
yes thank thank you cardinal if
anybody's
look if anybody's acting up uh
because we have open chat we just want
to be having a
discussion and making sure that
everybody is uh
on on task with python so like i said we
have some admins here to
clean up clean up anything all right
so all right so like i was saying string
python has handled some things for
strings to be able to tell if it
is numeric so let's just look at it
is str dot
is is lower is numeric here we go
numeric boom return true
return true if the string is a numeric
string so basically
python can understand that
here we go so
that minus
one is
numeric boom
true so python is able to look and see
and realize that this is a value
and it is a number so now now let's look
at
some list comprehension
with some conditions and this took me
forever to really
wrap my head around so if you give it
one condition
you have to lay it out a certain way and
then if it's two conditions you can lay
it out
a separate way sorry name
false but i hope everybody has been
doing good it has been now two weeks
since we've been together
in x if
str i
dot is numeric
boom boom so all right what did i do so
i did my
normal loop i just need to bring chat up
so we can see how everybody's doing
today
all right for i for i and x
then i'm wanting to return
false if
i analyzing i string
is that right yeah is numeric
so let's run this oops
and yeah
that doesn't need to be right there
there we go
all right so name yeah name
boom so false false false now
let's say i wanted
two conditions so like i said if you're
passing
one the condition needs to be at the end
now if i were to be
cut
actually i don't want to do that
name
false
if str
dot i dot is numeric
else
true for i
and x all right so let's see the
difference
so if it's one condition the f goes at
the end
but this is if you look at this
here's my eye for i and x
do either one of these and you can put
these at the beginning
so if this
do this else do this all right
so we can comment that out or not
because this will be the last
thing that name will be so now we have
our
true false true false true false
so
there and there so now now we're going
to take into account
and now we want to look at any
and all so basically these are two more
functions from let's do any
built-in function module uh from
built-ins from the built-in module
return true if boolean x is true
for any of the iterable for any
so basically remember how we had
and or so this is a function for an
iterable
so if you had two conditions true and
false
true or false
you got true but if it was true
and false
it's false any and all is the same for a
group
all right so now name
any name is
true are any of them true
yes true are all of them true
false so now i think if
so if we were to go and change that
scenario but
actually yeah let's do this
let's get true
and then all so names should be
all true right so all
name now that's true so all right does
that make sense to everybody
all right we do have a lot of comments
we got a lot of folks here today
um so all right that was that
now all right so we looked a little bit
more into some strings
um cardinal and jan have we done join
for string uh the function uh the
join method i can't remember
all right so let's look at help
str dot
join so all right this one was a little
odd for me to wrap my head around
of why why this wasn't
in the um list
or iterable function or things like this
so all right
so join is a method
it is it concatenates any number of
strings
so the reason why it is
a string method is whatever you pass it
is the glue so
actually i'm getting ahead of myself we
need to first look at the difference
between list and split
so like i said we got we got a lot to do
so hello
hello everyone how are you
so all right so i just made
took a simple string and assigned it to
uh to hello now
if i do hello dot
split i get a list
of everything
it is splitting on whatever i pass
it typically without anything being
passed
yes split
the delimiter what it separates on is
a is a white space
there it is any white space so now i can
pass it a value and go through but this
automatically
it splits typically into whole words
awesome okay so we we will go over
okay we did use zip all right so join
is the glue of how it's basically the
reverse
of split so split goes
it operates on a list excuse me on a
string to go to a list
then you pass in a iterable typically a
list
to join with the glue so alright
so now the glue so we have
uh let's let's change
here we go hello
split all right cardinal is
has everybody calmed down with the
spamming
and
yes this is for beginners so when this
is our and jan and cardinal you have to
remind me
uh this is our what ninth one
i think so so there are the this is our
ninth video in the series
and beau has done an awesome job
and yes this will be posted immediately
right after
beau with free code camp does an awesome
job and we have our own playlist
so you can go back and watch all of
these in consecutive order
and for just admin purposes
all of these videos are redone of
the first videos on my channel so
this is basically a recap with some
different variations and some different
consolidations
that i've learned to make sure we group
things together so all right
hello dot
split so then
hello split so all right
so now i have this and it was separated
on my on our white spaces
so now here's where the glue comes
and since this is a
[Music]
so since our glue is a string this is
why
join is a
string method
so now when i pass i use the glue
use the join then i pass it our iterable
i get this
we are we are i just want to make sure
we go over because we're going to be
using
all of these things here momentarily and
that was just something that we needed
to go over
that that was asked about with any and
all so all right
uh we'll we'll expand upon this
shortly so let's just go ahead and
get get to it all right
so we have we have quite a few
challenges
to to overcome first we need to build
an array here a list of lists so we're
actually going to use
a nested list comprehension so let's
just go ahead
and get into it
so we're gonna we got our array and
just like i like to say we're gonna go
for
[Music]
i in range so we got what one two
three four five six range
six close this out
so our i all right
now we want
that six times but now we want
six across so guess what
for i in range
six
and then we just want
letter o's capital letter o's all right
anybody lost so far
yeah i i think we'll be maybe a touch
over
uh an hour i think that's about uh
as much time as all this will take and
all this
stuff can be pretty complicated and i
don't want to overwhelm anybody so all
right
does everybody see what i did here
all right so
so let's print this out for i
in array print i
boom okay
so i just made that six
yeah boom six six six by six
now that doesn't look like
this so now what i need to do
is i need to line this up
yes you can do this in pycharm i just
know for beginners
i don't want this to be anything over
complicated
that's why i still use
the shell in the script because it is
satisfactory for what we're doing we're
not bringing in complicated modules and
we're not
uh doing anything sophisticated enough
to need that
so that's why we're still here because i
don't want to scare anybody away
that's the whole point of everything
that i do so
we need to neaten this up we need to put
this
we need to put this together so all
right
so we need to go print
uh did to do to do
dot join well first we need to go
through one at a time
for i in array
print so we're going to use our join
and then we're going to pass it i right
cool all right so building blocks
and that's one of the things that you'll
hear me talk a lot about
is that to go very very slow incremental
at a time
and um
and make sure we can do this so now
now we need to handle our
our uh i guess our equivalent of our x
and our y so our because
this is map coordinates a
and a numeric value so now
we're going to use the tools that we
have at hand
all right so we have string import
string everybody remember this i think
we touched on this
a while ago so we're just going to use
the as key
strings so der
string because excuse me
so as key lower as key
so str
for loops go a certain number of time
the length of an errable a
range function but an iterable
while is until that condition changes
and we're going to be using a while loop
in our example
and as you can see here the length of
this
is six times so it comes down here until
it's exhausted
until the iterable is exhausted
that's basically the difference between
the two good question
all right string
[Music]
dot as
key dot lower case
oops
boom forgot that's an attribute you're
very welcome
uh was that sebastian
i love it thanks john all right so now
we're just gonna use
the first six so then we're not going to
import everything
from string import
as key
lowercase
as i think what i think i think i like
doing this as
letters yep as letters
all right so then letters
oh yeah we're just going to use a
through f
equals so then since this is going to be
a string
we're just going to chop this off right
here first six
so letters
then yep six
so we'll bring this in and i'll show you
so
a underscore f
f boom just like this
so then if i wanted to
just like we learned
a little bit ago
because so the difference between split
and list
is split changes it splits it on the
white spaces or whatever
the delimiter we choose list
changes everything so let's do hello
again
uh list equals
oh yeah hello
everyone this is good enough so when i
do
list on hello
every single item
in the iterable is broken out
and that will become handy and we will
use that
very soon in our example so now
so now a underscore f which is our first
six letters
we're gonna wrap this in list
so now a underscore f
so now i have my abcd
efg stopping it f
sorry all right
everybody good
you want to print hello okay
boom well i just ran that up here so
that's hello just makes it nice and
pretty and there's actually a
uh way to print things even prettier in
python but those are the awesome skills
that we have
all right so now we have
this so we are getting very very slow so
now we need to take
and get our numbers over here
so now we need to set this up
so num equals list
range dot six
now is that right
how's this out so we got num right
zero through five that's not going to be
right because we want
one through six because we know we could
have it be
zero through five but the user will
probably not want to tolerate
that and i don't know why i keep doing
that
so start stop
exclusive so now let's run this again
let's call num there we go one through
six
so now now let's see if we can get this
board
to get the letters and the numbers at
the top
so right now we just need the
letters first okay so print
we have our list okay
print a underscore
f let's just start here
all right so that's not right
so oh yeah we need to put this in a
string
that's right we're using join
oh here we go but now why why don't we
make that's not
that's not pretty we need to make that
capital don't we shouldn't we
don't we want to so
uh how do we do that anybody remember
how do we take a letter and make it
capitalized
any takers
oop
so
let's see
to be honest i guess i can't find out
where i did this do i have this all in
upper i wonder if i have this in upper
somewhere else
ah why don't we do this
this will change it right here let's get
rid of this
i thought i found all this there we go
so let's see what i did here so this
brings this string
in as letters right
so all these are lowercase i slap an
upper at the end of it
converts all of it and then i'm slicing
it
so that's why this works right here
and like i said i can't find this
anywhere else in my main program
to see where i convert all those
ah i had this as upper case so let me
show you two ways to do this
so all right let's make sure i didn't
lose anybody
all right is everybody okay with this
right so that's
uh no when i had it down here because
that's
working on a list so
i did this here but i did not look at my
notes
so all right you can have this is upper
and then also and inside uh
let's see import string
dir on string it has
upper upper case right here
so upper
oops clean that up
there we are so you have one of two
options so it's
if you want two if you want to have them
bases lower case
and then you want to come back or you
can also come and pull this
in uh i guess i thought i
yeah but we probably won't get to flask
for a very long time we have
we have months before we'll get to that
and then you could argue that django's
better than flask because then you don't
have to do as much
setting up because flask is very very
very very bare bones very very
lightweight django
has a little bit more you have to do a
little bit more heavy lifting but
boy does it take care of a lot of stuff
for you all right we can have that
discussion later
all right uh so now we have
now we need to handle our
numbers on the side so all right
i want to show you something remember
how we did
uh iterables and
iterators so all right
we're going to turn this into an iter
and you might ask why
so we don't have to deal and count and
do things
and we can just interject
so we got num and we don't have to
overthink this
so we can literally just drop in
this and we don't have to fight and we
don't have to change this and do
anything over complicated we can just go
grab our next
drop it in and not overthink and not
have to count
and have an index and do anything crazy
so we can just go num now we do have to
handle
an issue here all right
all right so now we caused another
problem
so we have our one through six but we're
off a little bit here
so we got boom boom
let's see if that solved it
off a little bit
perfect so here we go
yes absolutely um you can go back
and search for inside free code camp
and type in python basics or you can go
to the playlist and you you can see
all the other videos all right enter
let's let's go over that
real slow again so if
the reason why i changed that that list
to a iter
is because if you're trying to go
through two functions
excuse me two iterables at the same time
because i'm using this as a marker i
would have to then
take this as an index and i would have
to change
and go through and have some count
but when i turned it into an iter
i can just go and grab each of these
next one at a time and i
don't know where
okay great great question we probably
have a lot of new
people here today so
so right here inside the print function
shoot is this at the bottom all right i
think i have this scaled right
okay good all right so
end what does it do at the end of the
print
it defaults to new line
this character right here backslash n
is newline what i'm doing is i'm
reassigning it
and i'm suppressing that newline
function
so see right here i have
end is get a new line i'm telling python
suppress go to a new line and cont
stay on that same line that's why this
basically is on this line right here
then after this line is executed then a
new line happens
on my channel in the link down below
there's a link to my channel
you can go and look at number shapes
triangle
uh triangle numbers reverse triangle
there's a whole series they're just
about
five videos on number shapes and it goes
real in depth
of what this end uh suppression
does right here the end argument inside
the print function
so all right it is very handy to do a
variety of things
so great question i love having a bunch
of new folks here and i'm glad we have
chat open
so i want to tell bo and quincy thank
you for doing that
all right so we are getting
very very close now we need to handle
some logic
of how to go about
doing this so we're gonna need to put
this
in a while loop so let's
come up with
a true and then we also need to then
take in some input oh and i think my
favorite part
is this right here well actually we also
need to come up with some hidden values
so all right there's a variety of ways
to do it but i'm a very
excuse me i'm a very simple guy
so what our goal is is we're gonna when
we guess
where an x is we're going to have the o
get removed then show that x
in location then if the guess is
not a has an x
it goes and just becomes a blank space
so we need to we have we need to handle
a lot of things right here
all right so first we need to indent
this
so i'm going to show you oops and
boom boom
all right so what i did and i did not do
tab
uh i did indent region because if you
get into the tab
issue you will have all kinds of
all kinds of issues don't ever pick one
do it i'm not going to sit here and be
just do spaces just do
tabs whatever your preference is but
don't mix them you will have a headache
and you'll want to you'll go nuts
so all right uh let's see we have our
we have our um
everything right here but now we need to
come up with our guesses
so now we're going to randomly
so we need to we need to look at random
import
random because we want the game
and it's just a simple game and yes it's
100
um uh true all this is is to get you to
think about how to do
how to handle the things that we already
know
all right so we're going to look
at choice inside random so help well
first let's look at it let's see what
our choices are
for random random all right
and we have choice right here so what
does
random choice do random.
choice choose a random element from a
non-empty sequence
so basically that's going to go but now
we're actually literally going to mix
and match
we're gonna take a choice out of each of
these and we're gonna come up with four
so now we need to go through four
times and pick
four hidden so we're gonna have a list
of we're going to have a list of choices
here
and this is going to determine how many
we have left
so i know it's really simple but i
remember the first time i learned
how to take basically examine
and have this change each time you guess
correctly i don't know
like i said i'm uh i'm a pretty simple
guy
all right so now we need to look at some
more list comprehension
so for i in range
four we just want four guesses
so now now let's throw this
inside of a list so we have
our list of letters
and our iterable of numbers
our iter right there iterator our
iterator of functions
our iterator of numbers excuse me so we
have choice
and then we're just going to go a
underscore f
because we want that one to be first now
and then we're going to do
let's see choice we need to handle
another problem here
if i can type today sorry everybody
and
oh i know what i did here helps if i
spell correctly
let's bring this over just a touch so we
can see
everything and we are just going to
clean this up
so we can have complete control because
you
cannot choose because you have a
iterator
you cannot pull out that was
and do
all right
and we have one more problem here so if
this is a number so if i wanted to
concatenate
a string because this is a this is a
list of letters
that's a string and this is going to be
a number
we can't concatenate
we cannot concatenate a string and a
number
all right everybody good with this
uh yes there's actually yes there is a
seed function
in um and there's a there's actually a
video on my channel that is actually
quite popular it's very interesting
seed is repeatability for random numbers
so basically
if i were to tell you that um i made a
random list of fifty thousand numbers
and i started with the seed of two
random dot seed two you and i could have
the same list of random numbers it's
actually one of the very cool
things about uh oh am i buffering
did i just drop out
all right am i back up okay
looks like i'm back up
so if you were to concatenate
and i would want to have a
letter and a number like
string a is numeric
string i have to convert it
to a string and there's two ways to do
this
longhand and shorthand so you wrap it in
the string function
so now i'm going to come over here str
and wrap this up so basically i'm we're
we're going to look at this
yes this is a lot here but i want you to
look at this so that
over here is my 4i in range that's our
our regular uh for loop
and then right here is a concatenated
very simple see how i did
oops
and what did i forget
i left something out let's see where it
is
i have an extra suppress set of
parentheses
i need one more there we go
and i forgot a while play
there we go
we don't need this right now
all right so now let's look at hidden i
don't know why
everything is freezing up on me
forgive me guys
all right that go through oh no is it
messing up the stream
i don't think i have too much running
but it i may be
let me close some stuff down sorry guys
whoa
i don't have the best computer but i
also don't have the absolute slowest
computer either
i thought i shut everything down but
guys i am so so sorry i am in the dark
right now with what i have running
i can't see you i have no idea
if you can see me i can't get to
x
it appears that the stream is good i
can't see
chat so i'm just going to keep going
all right i'm shutting this down
all right let's rerun this
okay
from random import
choice all right let's get this resized
so i usually restart my modem
before the stream looks like i'm going
to be restarting
my computer before the stream too all
right
there we go
okay
we're good okay good all right
yeah sorry guys everything was just
locking up i guess
i don't know what i had running in the
background
all right okay
so now here are my random choices
we're going to instead of so this is
what i want you to think about
instead of us over complicating this and
going okay we're going to assign and
then
have it hidden and this and that nope
we don't care what this is we're just
going to see if they type in values that
match these
so we're going to take input so we're
going to the board is going to look like
this
and then when these are either met or
not met
then we're going to do something does
that make sense
if these conditions are met or not met
all right so now
now we need to come in here and we need
to do
handle our while loop oops
so basically
uh because we don't we if we were to
just let this
if we were to do this right now run this
what would happen
it would just run over and over and over
and over and over and over again
oh no it wouldn't i forgot that was the
also built up back in
so you run out of next it stops but we
can also control this
by our um
let's see
and now the other thing is is then we
need to
run this down here
each time through so numer
then range
one through seven there we go
all right and then we need to take input
from the user after we print
our little our little map so move guess
so we're just going to do move input
1 2 3 because we want multiple
multiple lines q to quit enter move and
then just like that
so q2
quit and come down here
enter move
eg example
of a
five
one two three all right
and i forgot to close that out all right
so now we need to handle this
if move dot lower
equals q
then we take then we change
play to false
to kick out
false and to a dyslexic person that
looked exactly right
all right so let's see how close we're
getting okay
here we go all right everybody follow
along along so far
all right cool so we have
our top coordinate we have we have our
uh
x coordinate we have our y coordinate
and then if we type in q
we get out so all right so now we need
to handle how we are going to
handle the guesses and what we're going
to do
so now we need to do a lot of a little
thinking so
we covered indexing with lists
jan cardinal can you remember if we've
done
if we've done that before because i
don't want to jump directly into it if
we haven't
so it's actually some pretty
oh we need to handle this right here
so that is going to print each time
through our while loop
and to test this we're going to we're
going to put our
hidden so we can test and make sure all
right
okay so here are hidden here's our
hidden information because we do want to
see it
so that we can test and make sure that
it's working properly that is probably
the biggest thing that
i can i can say
is that you also want to test the
positive scenario or the scenarios that
you're expecting
i always love teaching young people when
they say
it didn't work or it didn't do it right
because they're expecting something and
something else came out
and they couldn't dare be wrong so it
has to get
uh it has to be the computer it couldn't
be the program that they wrote
so
all right so we're going to work off
this in a minute all right let's get
let's get out of here
no no no no i'm sorry let's go over
lower and low and lower case
for just a second lower case
is from lower case and upper case
is from the string module as key lower
and what i did with
lower lower is a method
from as a string and it's right
here so i run dur on my object and i get
a list of all the methods
and then i come in here and i do
str lower i run help on str lower
and it returns a and it tells me what it
actually
does and how to use it so return a copy
of the string converting to lowercase
and this is vital
if it's in place returns none or
what it returns if you haven't seen me
talk about that
this is very important to understand the
actual functionality of the method
so this this one returns a copy so it
will not do it in place
so right here
we'll do sam then i go lower
so here let's just go let's
let's m
all right name so all right so now i go
name.lower
all came out but it did not change name
so if i were to go lower then name dot
lower name still same
stays capital lower
because i'm returning something i'm
creating something return is a very
important word in python
i cannot say that enough so this creates
something return
creates something so now if i'm creating
something i have something to assign
something to so i'm taking this return
value which is a copy of
the lower of the original string
assigning it so that's why now i have
two variables
right there all right
all right is that good okay so
all right we're almost an hour in so
let's see if we can
run through this real fast so we have
our if
so now let's do an else
so now basically what we're wanting to
do uh pass let's bring this in
not to scroll up so we are wanting to go
and take let's in
this over i guess we don't need
to be able to see that anymore we know
what that did
there we have all that all right
so now we're going to take and we want
to check and see
so right now well that that's going to
change in a minute
but the hidden will stay the same once
once we're in our for loop
so oh i guess
we can do this right here so all right
so what the goal is is if i match one of
these
i want something to change
and also if i don't match it so if i
match it i want it to change
to an x and if i do not match it i want
it to change to a blank space
so we got some stuff to do so now
actually we need to talk about n we know
n
is in our um
when we do our range uh when we do our
for loop
have i explicitly talked about in jan
uh cardinal have i talked about those
you guys uh if i explicitly talked about
that
all right so right now i have hidden
right
so i have f f4 c6
c6 ooh
do i handle this i got i got c6 twice
and a4
so let's see
if i handle that to see if
oh that would be later at another date
because we are going to handle this
guesses in a minute so let's rerun this
all right we'll use
we use this hidden i did not think about
that when i was building
this originally so all right let's look
it in the in
the end keyword anybody remember how to
get to
keywords because especially since we got
a lot of new
people here today help
in all right so let's look at
what n does
well it'd be 30
would it be 36 to 1 i guess to repeat
would that be 36 times 36
to 1. all right so n basically is a
keyword
it's a membership test operation
is it a member
so let's rerun this and get one back in
here
so i have no way check that out f's all
the way across
so just like when i did name
sam
stay consistent sam in
name
all right so is
basically whenever you see something
like this
i always like to tell new
people to put the word put the question
is in front of it is s in name
true so now
let's go
f2 in
in hidden true
f lowercase f2 in
hidden false so we're going to be doing
a comparison so we're going to be taking
user information user input right here
and are we going to and we're going to
match it so is it in this
and if it is do one thing if it's not
do another that's basically what our
comparison our membership test is
and anytime you
can't remember exactly because i hated
that it
it took me probably two years and not a
lot of places
well i stumbled across it i don't think
i've ever written seen anybody
you can run help on any function and
method
but the only way to get to a keyword is
through the help prompt
all right and the as you can see
with the help prompt it is
you can end up going down a rabbit hole
so there is a ton of information
and like i s and then you can lead to
other you end up going down a rabbit
hole
keywords
boom so just like this
and you can just start and you can go
from there
all right so let's quit out of here so
now we have our two scenarios that we
need to handle
if it is in and if it's not in
so let's get after this
so we're actually going to have like i
said
two if move in
hidden
pass then else
pass all right and the reason why you
use pass is you know it's going to be
there but you don't want it to throw up
while you're kind of looking at it
so now now we need to and maybe at a
later time we can go in and we can
uh look at how to handle
and only have certain guesses because
i'm going to give you
a hint of how to handle this
so again like i was talking about we're
going to start doing more with lists
um pop the pop method
for a list have we done that yet i don't
think we have
all right so we're going to do help
list dot pop it's a very interesting
method
i think we did do it so it does and
if you and i think we have a lot of new
people here today so we're going to go
over real slow
does two things and you know it does two
things because it tells you it does two
things right here
remove and return so basically
we did do it in the horse example
awesome thank you jose
so and you guys are this is why i love
doing
uh these live streams especially with
chat and everybody coming and going
um awesome
and for you guys who are hanging out
here and have been around a long time
thank you you guys make my life a lot
easier
and i appreciate you guys being admins
too
all right so it does two things it's
going to remove it from the list
and if necessary you can then assign
that value because it returns it
so you can have it come so as you pull
it out
that that method is removing it and then
that that that value that popped value
can be assigned to a new value if you
want it to move someplace else
especially moving from one list to
another
that is uh i can't remember
there's a good example i have some
somewhere floating around but yes
this is probably one of the coolest ones
because it can do two things at a time
and it defaults to the last item so all
right
let's keep moving like i said we're
already an hour in i don't want to go
over too long because uh you guys are
you guys are up late i think okay
so if it matches we want
to have it convert the
zero o to an x
and if it does not match we're going to
convert the capital o
to a blank space uh
shoot that just made me think of
something that i don't think i handled
ah we need to talk about this this array
so the array is this
for i in array
and we need to talk about this for a
minute
if i can type all right
so i want to change this
one right here so it is the first
uh row and then the
one two three column
so i want you to think about that so
python goes
zero one two three four five
zero one two so
zero and zero one two
so since we know that lists are mutable
because this is a list of lists i can
change lists
so i'm going to change this one right
here to a blank space
so what i say 0
0 1 2.
for i in array
print i
so i said i wanted this one right here
to be a blank space
and i did it all right does everybody
follow that
okay everybody good with that because
this is our building block of how we're
gonna go about doing this
so it's my it's a list of lists so i
have my
first my first list
index first one and then my second one
all right when we go over that again
all right so
if i index my zero index is my first row
and then zero one
two three four five
so now
zero i'm going to change the last item
the fifth one
to a x
boom
so because
this is a list of lists right so my type
for array is a list then
type for array index 0
is also a list then
my type
array 0 and really any item
but we'll just do 0 0 type
is a string so whole thing
list first index
list second layer of indexing
string all right
all we're doing is kind of just laying
out a very
simple i mean it is a
very very rudimentary uh battleship
but the reason why i like this example
is because you have to use
um lists of lists list comprehension
uh choice from the random library uh
a little bit of logic a little bit of
planning throwing in
some uh some
new line suppression and uh
things like this it is just a huge
conglomerate
of everything that we've been learning
so far
so all right
i love that find a game of finding uh
hidden nexus
i love that oh we could call it treasure
hunt
there we go i guess it's like uh what an
old version i'll really show my age here
in a minute uh
uh minesweeper that but it's also
not as complicated so all right first
all right so we have hidden right here
now we need to get this i love that f2 5
f2 f5 f6 f4 so now we need this each
time through
we need to get this to print out how
many
how many are left how many x's are left
so let's do that so print
f dot
find the
when of hidden oops
bracket and then
hidden
hidden x's
so all right let's go over what i did
here
so i have a string
and each time through i'm having this
count how many how many do we have in
here
so each time we find one of course our
hidden list will get smaller
and this number will change so the user
will know
how many two that he's got
that they have to find left all right
now we need to deal with this
so if the guess if the move
if your move is in this list so if that
move is in the list
hidden dot pop
hidden dot index
that we need to look at index all right
we looked at pop i did not i can't
remember if i asked you guys if
we did index so hidden what that does
is then
help on list
dot index
okay return first index of value
so basically what this is
is so i want to find
where this is
all right and then i want to
take that and i want to remove it
all right
uh let's see
because i want to
there we go
take that out and then i'm gonna then
slice
i need to slice up my array so this work
right
here this is our building block
let's see then move equals list
because you remember how we took our
information
and if i pass
oops
a5
i separate it because this is important
because then i'm going to match these
and pull these out because i have my
row and my column
all right and then my array
and here's my location right int
move one
now why am i going to need to subtract i
need to tweak this a little bit
and y and we'll go over this in just a
second
i need to type and concentrate
move zero
and wrap that up
equals x
all right now you remember how we
adjusted this
we know in python that it's a zero index
so when we wanted to change our
first
our first one but it's the zero index
zero and what we changed
that one right there
zero and then zero one two
and that was the one we changed so we
are subtracting one
because of the zero indexing effect
the user won't tolerate
this being zero they want it one through
six so they know it's the sixth row
they're not going to put up with
going so we need to adjust our logic and
our planning
and so we subtract one
now all right
let's test this and we're gonna go
a five
so see that
i don't know why i typed a5 it clearly
says a4
boom so two things happened
we removed actually i guess three
because
we have this self
so here's our hidden list it was a4 i
typed a5
because apparently i can't read so then
we redid it
it jumped back out so i typed in
a4 removed that from the list
then adjusted this and said hey you have
three more left which all that is has
taken the len
then changed our zero to an x
all right so let's make sure that
that works all right so now i'm just
gonna guess
wrong b6
okay but that didn't
do anything so now we need to quit
and now we need to handle what happens
when
oops
all right now we need to handle what
happens when
the move is wrong
move equals list move
so say same thing
exact same thing
and then what happens is we go
and you know i'm not a big fan of
copying
because too many things can go wrong all
right
so here we are so we're gonna test
b two b two
cool now let's do b1
okay good
f6 okay good so it's just going blank
then let's do this one c4
oh no it's on our list let's do c3 c3
okay now c4 awesome
so there we go guys this is just
a wonderful little tool for us to really
start
laying these out and you can take this
and you can make this more sophisticated
less sophisticated whatever you want to
do so we're about
uh 77 minutes in a great little stream
back so glad to be back um
love the uh love the help and the
support
from you guys oh that is a much bigger
delay than i thought
so i am i am very
so well either battleship or i think
somebody
commented back uh fine find the four x's
i i love that treasure hunt
or however but just a wonderful little
tool
of the things that we have learned and
in a small little
span of time that it just really gets
you thinking
uh the one with all the indexing
oh sure the one with all the indexing
all right
so what i'm doing
absolutely so right right here
is that the one
yeah absolutely all right
so the indexing so what i'm doing
is i'm finding the location
so move zero let's look at some move
let's go over this again real slow oops
so i i just quit so up here
move c so we have a
underscore f let's bring this over
great question so what i'm doing
is right now so move so i kind of have
this in reverse
because again we have to handle these
issues that the user
yes i have it over on my github
i have this continued all of the code
all right two things i'll jump back
i'm just using shell and the the
the idle from uh from from python
so all of this so i i add to this every
time
and then i've actually gotten to where i
saved the shell
in its own file with today's date so all
right
that was uh that was a little admin
there so all right
so let's go over this a little bit
so i take move and it's
c equals
c4 all right
so then i take move
let's go over this real slow great
question
list move
so now move is a list of two items
two strings and i'm doing them in
reverse here
because this
is this way python goes
rows then columns so that's why i'm
going in reverse
so row then column and you're
more specifically asking um about the
indexing
so i'm finding the index i'm having to
adjust
this by one to find the proper
because in python that's zero index so
if the user's four this is actually zero
one
two three that's why i subtract one now
the index effect
i'm not having to do any adjustment i'm
using the tools that i have
i'm using my second index and allowing
python to find that for me
and fill it in so i'm taking
my underscore dot
index and i'm passing it c
let's be consistent passing at c
and that's where i'm getting my two so i
know
that this is zero one
two so that's filling in so it's row
then column so that's what i'm doing
there with the index
all right did that answer that but that
was a fantastic question that's again
very much why i like these streams and
especially with the chats
but fantastic everybody so all right a
great stream today
we will be continuing on and if you guys
ever want to
review anything that we've gone over of
course
uh there are all the previous streams
and then over on my channel which is
in the link down below each video
each one of these topics has its own
micro video very small
uh the average video um
uh is and again it's the github link is
on every single one of my
uh videos over on my channel you can
just jump over there
and get right to it but we are right
here with this
all these are micro videos three to four
minute videos you can just go
buy search any of them i think today's
video will be 780 so there are
there are tons of things for you to be
able to go and get caught up on
but i just want to always take a minute
to say thank you to everybody who spends
their time here today
to beau and quincy i really appreciate
the opportunity
and to jan and cardinal i appreciate you
guys being admins and uh taking the
time to help and keep us on task so as
always guys appreciate you watching
don't forget to uh hit that subscribe
button and the notification
bell and the like button give this video
a thumbs up
and uh we'll see you guys next week bye
guys